In addition to thinking
about the major themes and
keywords to include in your targeted
resume, it is helpful to think about how
to structure your profession narratives
so that it tells an interesting story.
How can you do this?
By strategically ordering
the sections of your resume.
In the Master Resume section we
examined the various sections
your Master Resume should include.
In your targeted resume,
order these in an engaging and
meaningful way that is
appropriate to your background.
This is because the order of your
resume sections helps provide logical
evidence of your experience.
Whether you're just starting your
career, or making a career change, or
have many years of experience
within a single industry,
your resume will look
slightly different.
In the next section you'll see
some common resume structures.
Based on this information,
fill out your targeted resume and
see which order communicates your
goals and experience most clearly.